[تصفيق]
ما نقدمه لاوكرانيا ليس عملا خيريا فهل
حان وقت سداد الفاتوره بينما الغرب يعطي
زينينسكي درسا في الاخلاق لا تتمادى والا
سنغلق الحنفيه وسلاح روسي مرعب يعجز الجيش
الاوكراني باعتاده الغربي عن مقاومته وحرب
الجو تزداد ضراوه بالمسيره في اوكرانيا
وبوتين يقدم عرضا عسكريا لبريغوجوجين
والاخير يرد
17 مليار يورو
يحفظ هتلر ووشنط تدفع بالالاف من قواتها
الى اوروبا فما الذي يجري واول رد امريكي
على تجربه
الغرب يقولها
قالت الحرب ان قصرت فالمخزون الروسي لا
ينضب واسلحه بوتين تضع حدا للاسلحه
الغربيه او هكذا تقول التقارير وهو شاهد
غربي يشهد على ذلك الاستخباراتي السابق في
الجيش الامريكي
يعلن ان الجيش الاوكراني عاجز عن مقاومه
مسيره الروسيه الضاربه مشيرا الى ان تلك
المسيرات تدمر كل شيء في مسارها موضحا ان
الاوكرانيين ليس لديهم ايه وسائل لاسقاطها
او التاثير علي لاسلكيا ليعلنها رئيس
الوزراء هنغاريا فيكتور بان ان اوكرانيا
بلد غير موجود اقتصاديا معتبرا ان الحرب
في اوكرانيا ستنتهي بمجرد توقف الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي عن تقديم الدعم
المالي الى كييف بل ينظر الغرب الى خيار
كهذا الغرب من جهته ينظر الى خيارات اخرى
كيقاف الرئيس
عند حده مثلا وكما يقولها المصريون
على غيرك حيث افادت شبكه
الغربيين حذروه من انه تمادى كثيرا في
انتقاده لحلف ولذا ضغطت الولايات المتحده
والدول اخرى عليه لابداء مزيد من الامتنان
وماذا بعد الامتنان يا هؤلاء متى ستاخذ
هنا مقابل دعمكم المتواصل نعم الغرب لا
يقدم شيئا مجانيا وها هي الناطقه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريز خروفه تعيد نشر
تغريده لوزيره الخارجيه الفنلنديه
والتي دعت فيها الغرب الى ادراك ان ما
يعطيه لاوكرانيا ليس عملا خيريا لتقول
زخروفا انها محقه مئه بالمئه هذا ليس عملا
خيريا انه ارتزاق وقواده هناك خرج وزير
الدفاع الامريكي
ليؤكد ان كل عضو في النيتو اكد للرئيس
الاوكراني خلال القمه الاخيره فيلينيوس ان
اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في الحلف مهلا مهلا
مهلا لقد مللنا من عباراتكم الرنانه
اوكرانيا ستنضم للنيتو اوكرانيا ستنضم لو
كانت شمس لبنت من امس ليتولى هنا الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مسؤوليه الرد بقوله
ان موسكو لا تعرض مناقشه الضمانات الامنيه
لاوكرانيا مؤكدا ان لدى كييف الحق في ضمان
امنها لكن دون ان يؤدي ذلك الى الاضرار
بامن الدول الاخرى انه يقول لكم الحق ان
تضمنوا انكم لكن وفق الشروط الروسيه وبغير
ذلك لا امان لكم فهل وصلت الرساله لتصبح
بولندا اول من يستقبل الرساله الروسيه حيث
افادت الخارجيه الروسيه بانه تم استدعاء
سفير بولندا
الى مبنى الوزاره وتسليمه مذكره حول اغلاق
الوكاله القنصليه البولنديه في وليس ذلك
فحسب بل تحدثت موسكو ايضا عن مصادره
العقارات الدبلوماسيه الروسيه وسرقه
الاموال من السفاره الروسيه مشدده على انه
لن تبقى اي خطوه عدائيه من جانب السلطات
البولنديه موجهه ضد روسيا بدون رد لكن
هناك من لا يفهم الرسائل الروسيه او انه
يتجاهل ذلك متعمدا نعم نحن نتحدث عن
المستشار الالماني الذي تعهد بتقديم دعم
عسكري لاوكرانيا بقيمه 17 مليار يورو حتى
عام 2027 مبينا ان برلين هي ثاني اكبر
مساهم في ذلك بعد واشنطن يا الهي انهم
يتسابقون في فعل الخير لكن ما هو المقابل
الذي يريده من هذا ومن سبا
[موسيقى]
ان اوكرانيا تسلمت رسميا قنابل عنقوديه من
واشنطن مؤكدا على قوه هذا السلاح واهميته
واضاف في مقابله مع قناه سي ان ان القنابل
العنقوديه ستعطي افضليه للقوات الاوكرانيه
وستغير شكل المعركه وان العدو يدرك ذلك
حسب قوله وخلال كل هذه العمليات اعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه ان الجيش الاوكراني نفذ
عددا من المحاولات الفاشله للهجوم على
محوري دونيسكو
لتبلغ خسائر العدو نحو 670 جنديا في يوم
واحد وذلك بحسب تقرير الوزاره الروسيه
وعندك واحد مصدر للباشا واليكم المصدر في
القناه الرسميه للحكومه الروسيه من اعداد
الضحايا نعود لعروض بوتين الخاصه حيث عرض
الرئيس الروسي على زعيم مجموعه فاقن
مواصله خدمته العسكريه تحت مظله الجيش
الروسي قائد المجموعه رفض العرض وهنا يجب
ان نستعين بمصدر حيث نشرت قناه الغد
الفضائيه هذا الخبر بعد ان استندت الى عده
مصادر في الحكومه الروسيه وبين هذا وباك
ومع تزايد فرص التصعيد مع روسيا ولطمنه
الحلفاء الاوروبيين امر الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن بنشر قوه عسكريه من الجيش
الامريكي قوامها ثلاثه الاف جندي في
اوروبا وياتي القرار الامريكي رغم تحذيرات
بوتين المتكرره فهليا الرئيس الروسي
بوعوده هذه المره وهنا وبعد صدور التقارير
الغربيه بان صاروخ البالستيكي المرعبه
والعبر للقارات قد سقط فيلم
حصريه الروسيه للتنفيه ذلك المتحدثه
الروسيه مرياز خروفه قائله طالما اصبحتم
بهذه الدقه فمن برايكم يقصف محطه زبروجيا
وعلى ذكر صاروخ كيم اتخذت الولايات
المتحده اول اجراءاتها للرد حيث نظمت
واشنطن مع كوريا الجنوبيه مناورات جويه
مشتركه والتي شهدت مشاركه قاذفه
استراتيجيه من طراز
بالاضافه الى الطائرات اف تي من كوريا
الجنوبيه وطائرات من الولايات المتحده
على طريقتها الخاصه وعلى لسان شقيقه
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
التي هددت الولايات المتحده بردع نووي
ساحق ما لم تتخلى عما وصفته بسياسات
العدائيه ضد بيونغيانج
[موسيقى]